[Music]
well hello folks uh we're so glad that
you've decided to join us for this
program i'd like to know
uh as probably many of you know this
program is a q a program
where you can send us your questions and
we'll do the research and try and find
an answer
to your question
i want to give you the email address
where you can send us your questions
it's tv at some tv dot org you'll see it
on the screen tv at some tv
dot org we'd be delighted to get your
questions uh i must warn you though that
we receive many many questions and we
put them in the order in which they
arrive which means that your question
might be answered down the road always
but bear with us tune into the program
and i'm sure
that eventually we will get to your
question
i have with me today
daniel miranda
who in a short while is going to be
going to sweden to teach there for a
week
and we're very glad to have him here at
secrets unsealed
he's in charge of the spanish
aspects of secrets unsealed also does a
lot of english work and we're glad
you're here daniel thank you pastor bohr
for me it is a pleasure i i've said this
before in previous programs but i love
this program because it encourages me
and pushes me to study deeper the word
of god yeah it does me too and i've
learned a lot of things as a result of
the questions that people have sent i
have yes yeah
so basically we want to uh continue with
an answer that we began last time in our
last program but before we do we do want
to have a word of prayer to ask the lord
to give us guidance so would you pray
for us please sure let's pray
heavenly father
thank you once again for this program
i'd like to know we are so happy and so
delighted to be able to answer these
questions that you people have sent
and i pray lord that you may give us
wisdom you may give us clarity of mind
and your holy spirit to be able to
[Music]
tackle with the difficulties of your
word in such a way that may bring
redemptive answers we pray all these in
the name of jesus amen amen well just to
refresh the memory of those uh who are
tuning in uh yesterday we were talking
about isaiah 65 and verse 20.
and uh you know what we also briefly
mentioned isaiah 66 22-23 correct
so basically isaiah 65 verse 20 says
no more shall an infant from there live
but a few days
nor an old man who has not fulfilled his
days
for the sinner
for the child shall die 100 years old
but the sinner being 100 years old shall
be accursed
there are aspects in isaiah 65 that do
apply
both to the old testament and to the new
testament and there are others that
apply
to the future
so the question is what is the governing
principle that we need to apply
to decide
what is
what was supposed to be fulfilled in the
old testament with literal israel
and what applies
as a fulfillment in the end time what is
the governing principle it's a good
question if we go back to verse 17 we
see that this is spoken of in the
context of the new heavens and the new
earth
so
we should go to the last two chapters of
revelation
which actually echoes
the first two chapters of genesis
and there we have
the framework if you will the governing
principle
to decide and choose what aspects of
this
we can apply
to the new heavens and the new earth and
what aspects not and for example if we
go to genesis 1 and 2 we see for example
that there was no death okay we see
sabbath keeping we see the tree of life
we don't see animals destroying other
animals and killing other animals um we
see
um
a man and a woman so all these aspects
that we find in genesis 1 and genesis 2
before sin before sin
will also be repeated that god is going
to restore us back to his original
creation where there is no death nor
sorrow nor pain
so
even though some of the aspects here in
isaiah 65
may apply and
apply actually to the new heavens and
the new earth certain aspects like
the children dying after 100 years we
know that there won't be death in the
new heavens and the universe yeah
in fact the book of revelation
revelation 21 verse 4
tells us that there shall be no more
death exactly and
in
first corinthians chapter 15 verse 26 it
says the last enemy to be destroyed is
death it's death so isaiah
65 verse 20 cannot be talking about
something that's going to happen after
god makes a new heavens and a new earth
so the governing principle is that
whatever genesis describes before sin
and whatever revelation 21 and 22
applies to the future to the new heavens
and earth would still be applicable uh
at the end of time
whereas that which which is not
corroborated by genesis and by
revelation would apply mainly to literal
israel in the old testament and and many
of the things in isaiah were never
literally fulfilled with literal israel
even that verse wasn't fulfilled with
literal israel but it would have been
fulfilled if israel had fulfilled god's
plan
and we have many examples like
gog and magog
and prophecies of ezekiel
and then we have 38 and 39 36 the
promise of uh of the new covenant 37 the
dry the vision of the dry bones and then
as a result if they had fulfilled that
condition then you'd have you would have
had the war
of the enemies from gog and magog in
chapters 38 9 right but that war never
happened because the condition
in chapter 36 was never never fulfilled
and and you read ezekiel 38 and 39 where
you have the gog and magog prophecy and
you find that all of the description is
is in literal israel yes
you know it's it's not global
but the book of revelation chapter 20
takes
gog and magog 28-9
and it applies to all of the wicked that
surround the holy city that is descended
from heaven
and so uh and so that those verses
in the book of ezekiel are actually
globalized in the book of revelation
yeah without the details that that don't
apply right like the kind of weapons
they use right and
the time that the war would last those
things
but gog and magog prophecy is fulfilled
at the end of time but it's not
fulfilled in every single little detail
that is mentioned in ezekiel 38 and 39
amen
okay now there's another text which is
uh problematic is isaiah 66 we talked a
little bit about that as well
as adventists we've always used isaiah
66 22 and 23
um to apply to the end time
not not only
not only to literal israel although it
did apply to literal israel as well
but we've used it to apply
at the end of time
when god makes a new heavens and a new
earth
let's read those verses
and then we'll take a look at a
potential problem in verse 24.
you want to read those 66 22-23
22-23 okay
for us the new heavens and the new earth
which i will make shall remain before me
says the lord so shall your descendants
and your name remain and it shall come
to pass that from one new moon to
another and from one sabbath to another
all flesh shall come to worship before
me says the lord
what indications do we have in these
verses that they not only apply to
literal israel
but they apply especially to
the end of time
well we have first of all that
sabbath-keeping
and we also have the
from
new new moon to new moon that's month
uh and we find in revelation that the
tree of life yields a new fruit every
month okay so this would be a good a
reason why they would have to go every
month
to the city to jerusalem
and
we also find the new heavens and the new
earth that will remain
it says shall remain before me says the
lord and your descendants and your name
remains so we're
talking about here in an eternal
language like
that's what is going to remain forever
right
and also it says
all flesh in all flesh shall come to
worship before me says the lord in other
words it's not god doesn't say all the
jews
all
literal israel will come and worship
before me it's actually global it says
all flesh shall come to worship me but
then we have the problem of verse 24.
you know sometimes we shuffle that under
the rug uh hoping when we read verses 22
and 23 that uh nobody will see verse 24.
because verse 24 gives the impression
that as god's people are going from
month to month and as they're going from
sabbath to sabbath to worship before the
lord there's this grotesque spectacle
outside the holy city of all the
carcasses of those who sinned against
the lord
i might mention that the problem is with
uh many times with the translation
um let me just share with you this
interesting detail robert young
he was the one that compiled young's
analytical concordance which is one of
the most used concordances in the
christian world today
and he used the masoretic text for the
old testament for his translation and he
used the text as receptus for his
translation of the new testament
and the interesting thing is
that he was very aggravated by the way
in which verbs were handled
by generally by the translators
and so i want to read what he wrote
if a translation gives a present tense
when the original gives a past
or a past when it has a present
a perfect for a future
or a future for perfect
it is clear that verbal inspiration of
course we don't believe in verbal
inspiration but the principle of what he
says surprise
it is clear that verbal inspiration is
as much overlooked as if it had no
existence the word of god is made void
by the traditions of men another what
he's saying is that many times
translators will take a verb
that is past
and they'll make it future
now how does isaiah 66 verse 20 24
actually read in the hebrew
it reads like this
and they have gone forth
in other words
before in other words this is something
that they did before
they go from month to month and from
sabbath to sabbath
they have gone forth
and have looked on the carcasses of men
who have transgressed against the lord
for their worm does not die and their
fire is not quenched and they have been
on the florence on abhorrence of all
flesh
so in other words
the tenses of the which are perfect
you know it's a it's a
it's actually a perfect tense it's
actually an action that begins in the
past and
lasts for a period of time
so what isaiah 66 verse 24 is saying is
that when god makes the new heavens and
the north
that the people have seen before this
the carcasses of those who sinned
against the lord and of course
and of course the the
icing on the cake we might say that
proves that this is correct
is the book of revelation
because the book of revelation clearly
tells us
that the wicked are going to be
destroyed by fire from heaven and then
god is going to create a new heavens and
the new earth yeah so very clearly the
book of revelation is the key once again
to
tell us which translation of isaiah 66
verse 24 would be correct yeah
i remember when i first read this text
of course i had embraced the belief that
there was not a hell right now but i was
i was my mind went to the new heavens
and the new earth and i was like
i don't think i will feel happy about
seeing my friends that were lost when i
go to worship the lord seeing them still
burning and because the fire is not
quenched and the worm doesn't die i
wouldn't feel really happy about being
in the new heavens and new earth seeing
that spectacle
and you know it's interesting that uh
not only is there a mistranslation of
the tense of the verbs
but there is also uh taking liberties
with uh with
you know adding words that are not there
for example
many versions translate the worm never
dies
and the fire will never be quenched well
the word never is not there it's not
there yeah uh the the word in the new
testament by the way this is uh
jesus refers to isaiah 66 24 in mark
chapter 9 verse 45 where he's speaking
about ghana
or the valley of hinnom
and
there
basically the word for
that is translated never
is quenched is the word asbeston which
means
that it does not go out until it has
consumed everything that there is to be
consumed
it's fire that cannot be extinguished
until it fulfills its function of
destruct destroying the wicked but it
mean doesn't mean that things are going
to be consuming and consuming and
consuming forever
what kind what joy would there be for
god's people inside the holy city to see
that spectacle outside the city
furthermore
how could god make a new heavens in the
new earth if the wicked are all over the
earth burning up
it doesn't make any sense actually
that's how ellen y understood it
in early writings page 294 there is a
very nice quote it says here satan
rushes into the midst of his followers
and tries to stir up the multitude to
action
but fire from god out of heaven is
reigned upon them and the great man and
the mighty man the noble the poor and
miserable
all are consumed together i saw that
some were quickly destroyed
we talked about this in another program
while others suffered longer
they were punished according to the
deeds done in the body some were many
days consuming
and just as long as there was a portion
of them and consumed
all the senses of suffering remained
said the angel
the worm of life shall not die
their fire shall not be quenched and
this is the key here as long as there is
the least particle for it to prey upon
yup
and after that
god will create a new heavens and the
north
so um i hope that this is helpful uh to
those who are watching the program uh we
in isaiah 66 verse 24 we need to be
careful about words that are added we
need to be careful about the tense of
the verbs
and the basic principle for determining
in isaiah 65 and 66
what is
what applies to literal israel and what
applies at the end of time
is
whether genesis applies it before sin
revelation applies it after
sin is done away with and that will help
us with the governing principle about
how to read isaiah 66
and isaiah 65 as well
all right i hope that that is helpful
now we have a question here
that i'm going to give you free reign to
explain because
pastor miranda wrote a book
on the on romans
it's only in spanish i believe
hopefully it could be translated to
english it's a very it's a small book
but it's very very explanatory simple to
to read
you know it makes simple what is very
complex sometimes in the reasoning of
the apostle paul
but anyway i'm going to throw this
question at him because he's the expert
in the book of romans
this is the question
i am jonathan masilla from kenya
here is my question in romans 7 14-25
paul says that he is sold under sin
he says that he is willing to do good in
his mind but finds another law that is
against his will
he then says that the wrong that he does
that he is not willing to do
it is not him who is doing it but the
sin that dwells in him
then in verse 24 he cries and laments
because of his weakness in verse 25 he
thanks god for deliverance
but now he says
so then with my mind i serve the law of
god but with the flesh the law of sin
what does he mean by that
how does he serve the law of god and the
law of sin
simultaneously please help
yes
oh yeah i have received this question
many times
and actually this verse
is used by some to imply that the
experience of the wrong of the man of
romans 7 is the experience of a
converted man because he is thanking the
lord
that
i thank god
it says here with the mind i myself
serve the law
of god but with the flesh
the law
of sin
now oftentimes when we study romans
chapter seven we begin with the
discussion of the realm of the man of
romans seven with verse 13 and onward
but we forget that paul is
beginning his reasoning right from the
beginning in verse in chapter seven
actually even from chapter six
this whole section chapter six chapter
seven and chapter eight
paul is dealing mostly with the
sanctification aspect of salvation
sanctification by faith uh how to
live or experience freedom from sin
now here in chapter 7 verses 1 through 6
paul uses an allegory of a woman
that is married to a husband
and he says
that if she would marry another husband
while the first husband is alive then
she will be an adulteress
but if the husband dies then she is free
to marry another
man
now in this allegory the woman
represents each one of us that's what it
says here in verses four and five
the
or the church
first man or the first husband
represents the old man according to the
previous chapter chapter 6
the second husband
represents jesus christ so what was
happening here
some and he and paul is writing
verse 1 it says for i speak to those who
know the law he's writing to the jews
some were trying
to marry jesus
while the old man was still alive
and paul says this is a spiritual
adultery
and this is the experience of the man of
romans 7. he's trying to with his mind
he's trying to serve god i mean he wants
to serve god but he has a problem he
doesn't have the moral power to do it
why because he's not converted he says i
am sold in verse 14 it says
we know that the law is spiritual but i
am carnal
sold under sin this cannot be a
converted person so it's trying to get
the old man to live like a new man
without the new birth exactly and that's
the problem so it says here then with my
mind i sold my myself the law of god but
with the flesh the law of sin but
actually jesus said
in matthew 6 24 that we cannot serve two
masters
because we will love one and hate the
other so this one who is
although this person wants to do the
will of god in reality who is this
person serving
serving sin
so
is hating the other master but then in
romans chapter 8 we have a different
picture
because now we see
a man that does not only want to do good
but he's doing good right in verse 1 he
says there is therefore no no
condemnation to those who are in christ
jesus see if they're in christ jesus
then he's their master who do not walk
according to the flesh that's romans 7
but according to the spirit that's roman
8 for the love of the spirit of life in
christ jesus had made me free from the
love of sin and death but the other man
the man in romans 7 he was not free from
this law he was sold under sin he was
carnal
and he explains that it is the law of
sin that works in him
that
causes him to do
these things that he doesn't want to do
for the lord could not do in that it was
weak through the flesh god did by
sending his own son in the likeness of
sinful flesh and on account of sin he
condemned sin in the flesh that the
righteousness of the law might be
fulfilled in us who walk not after the
flesh but after
the spirit so clearly
uh
this verses in verse 25
is actually a summary of the entire
chapter of of romans chapter 7.
this is the experience of this man that
with the mind wants to serve the law of
god but with the flesh his servant
actually the love sin
i think that probably
one of the key aspects to explain this
is actually romans 6
because in romans chapter 6 the first
few verses says what shall we say then
shall we continue in sin that grace may
abound
certainly not how shall we who died to
sin
live any longer in it
or do you not know that as many of us as
were baptized into christ jesus were
baptized into his death therefore we
were buried with him in other words you
buried the old man
were buried with him through baptism
into death that just as christ was
raised from the dead by the glory of the
father even so we also should walk in
newness of life which is picked up on in
chapter 8.
so so basically paul is saying you know
if you have been buried with christ
and you have been born to a new life
you know
then you no longer have this struggle
between the the flesh and the spirit
because in chapter eight you have the
spirit guiding the life of the person
correct you know the victory has been
won
over the conflict that exists in chapter
seven yes
and and the struggle may continue but
this time it won't be overcome by the
flesh but the spirit will take control
correct yeah the spirit will take
control of
of the life of the person who has given
his will to god right now verse 25
another aspect
why is paul thinking because peop some
people say well if he is thanking god
that means that god is pleased with this
but that would be a parenthetical
expression when he says i thank god
through jesus christ our lord in
anticipation
of what he is going to write in romans 8
correct this is not thanking god because
i can with my mind serve the love of god
but with the flesh the law of sin no he
is not thanking god for that he is
thanking god
for what he is going to write in chapter
eight yeah it's kind of so so the last
verse is actually the bridge
between
what we find in chapter seven and the
amplification that he's going to give in
chapter that's correct yeah
okay so a very good explanation very
simple easy to understand
um anything else that we can say about
this are there any other passages in
scripture that come to mind that would
help explain this
well there are there are many um
here even in in chapter eight if we one
even want to go deeper
uh verse six for example for to be
carnally minded is death
but to be spiritually minded is life and
peace so going back to verse 25 if with
the flesh is serving the law of sin well
it says to be carnally minded is death
but to be spiritually minded is life and
peace because the carnal mind is enmity
against god for is not subject to the
law of god
neither indeed can be
that's romans 7 yeah
the flesh was trying to be subject to
the law of god but he couldn't and paul
says it cannot be it is impossible for a
carnal person without going through the
new birth experience it is impossible to
keep the law of god to be subject to the
love of god so then those who are in the
flesh
cannot please god clearly the man in
romans 7 is in the flesh therefore that
he cannot please god so he is not
thanking god
for that because clearly we see here
that
those who are in the flesh cannot please
god and definitely the man in romans 7
is in the flesh
so is the man of romans 7 maybe an
illustration of the apostle paul before
he came to accept christ into his life i
believe so
and there is an import an interesting
word here in verse 24
because he concludes his experience
saying oh wretched man that i am who
will deliver me from the body from this
body of death
it's kind of like a cry of despair yes
it's a cry of despair and that word and
this is strong but that word wretched in
the greek
appears only one more time in the new
testament
in the message of laodicea yeah
and describes the laodicea as wretched
miserable poor blind and naked so in
other words
what makes this man more wretched
is because now he has the knowledge of
the law but he doesn't have the power to
keep the law yeah leo odyssey has the
knowledge of the law
right right right right right right
right law this is knowledge of the bible
and now has the spirit of prophecy
but is not living according to that lie
that god has given you we don't use the
word wretched very much in english i
like the spanish translation
[Laughter]
so wretched means miserable miserable
yeah well uh i trust that our program
today has been interesting to you uh we
greatly enjoy working together and
answering questions thank you for
joining us may the lord bless you and
keep you in his care and we hope to see
you the next time
[Music]
you